I know you're a big fan of one direction
I have to ask you this because one of
the one of the one of the perks of now
that you're on TV is you sometimes get
to meet your heroes I understand you got
to meet what happened oh my gosh what
happened it's almost embarrassing but
here we go
yes I'm a huge fan of One Direction I am
I've loved them since the beginning and
I recently was at one of Harry Styles
show yeah yeah and yeah I was I was
backstage with my sister and you know I
had met the boys like briefly here and
there similarly I would always remember
of course they would never remember and
um so we were backstage in the green
room and Harry comes in and everybody's
kind of like looking at him and then all
of a sudden he looks over my way and his
eyes like light up what and he starts
coming towards me with his arms
outstretched and he started shy do you
like his voice sure okay he's like no
he's like you're killing it I'm so proud
of you oh yeah he's like everybody's
talking about what a good job you're
doing he's like um what a promotion
which I'm like I got a second season or
so yeah like that's British for that and
it was like the best moment of my life
and I have been married I mean I bit I
mean I'm married I'm Erica still married
married you're still married
yeah
and you know we have like a lovely
little chat and he walks away and my
sister and I kind of like grab ham sorry
that's cool and you know like I'm
freaking out and then a few minutes go
by my sister and I are sitting on this
couch and he looks over and he's like
what are you two talking about and I'm
like mind your own beeswax hairy because
at this point we're like birds right and
he goes everybody to this whole green
room he's like you just got a promotion
and she can't stop talking about it give
it up for Sue and this entire green room
starts clapping right cuz my name is not
sue sue sue right sue is somebody who
Harry is so nice to he obviously loves
this person it is not me such a great
friendship I'm sorry like the highest
high in the lowest low yeah I called my
husband after her and told him and he
was like you know what this means you
have to become sue now you now must be
sued you don't you got out of it though
this is we have a picture of you and
Harry before he realized you're not the
person he thought you were
and he looks pretty confused
you